hey what up though hey salute all the
gangsters bozo I'm on the boole cafe
show tune in give us a view you know the
business
bootleg cab show we in the building
special guest in here
we got the homie Bozo appreciate it
thank you welcome welcome you just
dropped a new project too yes sir um
Thursday the 29th well by the time this
comes out the project will be out yeah
no last year oh last Thursday so it's
already out okay I'm like wait 29th
we're in the middle of October beginning
of October
um well [ __ ] welcome man I know we've
been trying to make it happen for a
while yeah yeah I appreciate it yes sir
for people it's like a joke nah it's all
good man nah
um how uh for people who don't know who
you are where you're from how long
you've been making music give me kind of
just like a background so
um I go by the artist thing well my own
name too Bozo I kept my handle you know
yeah it means too much to me I'm from
the city of Pico Rivera Southeast Los
Angeles
um born and raised bread in my hood
um I've been rapping I got science team
reversal in 2004.
um I was four months into my deal I
caught a term for um string of armed
robberies and assault with a deadly
weapon
um I went to prison for 10 years two
months I paroled in the summer of 2015
and they hit the ground running and I've
been doing my [ __ ] ever since
independently wow
was it hard to
I feel like if you do 10 years in prison
kind of like the music industry passes
You by technology passes You by before
you went in you were able to still sell
CDs and [ __ ] and you know Myspace was
still popping was it hard for you to
like get the motivation to pick back up
and like get back on the grind like when
you got out
um when I went to prison I stopped
writing music like I wasn't one of them
dudes in prison like with the [ __ ]
notebooks yeah because my situation I
didn't know if I was gonna make it home
to happen you feel me yeah I came home
early I was supposed to do way more but
okay changed and I was able to come home
after 10 years
um but when I came home
the access to like well you I'm sure you
know like back in days it was different
to get distribution oh it's a lot more
difficult to release music yeah yes yeah
to distribute your music legitimately it
was [ __ ] if you didn't have a plug like
it was hard yeah so that was encouraging
yeah you know and then um YouTube didn't
exists didn't exist when I went to
prison so YouTube was extremely
welcoming to to me because I felt like
that was avoided in my community
specifically of of growth and um
transitioning to different sounds and
new modern sounds you know I felt like
we were stuck in quicksand when nobody
was really pushing the envelope nobody
was really um trying to take risks you
know I mean as far as music so when I
came home I I saw a boy and I just took
it as an advantage what would you say
like after you got out was uh a moment
of success in the music industry that
kind of like made you realize oh you
were kind of onto something you had
something here that might work you know
obviously you were signed before you
went to prison but the first feature
with company ad okay my first Mutual
company dude was like early when I came
out and um company D had just dropped
that um you would never had a thug yeah
so that [ __ ] was popping so
um through a mutual friend of ours on
peep CNT dope man
um he linked us up don't believe that my
talent from the gate so he started
bringing me and he was always like um
you know with with what I represent
there's always the racial Factor like
hey are you open to work with these
people these people this me myself like
I'm down to do business with Arabic as
long as it's a good business right
um we could stand on it you know I mean
at the end of the day so yeah when I did
something with Compton indeed and then
um all my features came back to Mac
literally like it was Company ID that I
had to Joe's Moses then at the chief per
equal then I did RJ and [ __ ] 2015 2016
2017 those are the guys and by the way
still are the guys shout out to those
Joe Moses just dropped his album RJ's
albums coming soon Perico's about to go
on tour yeah so you could have match sit
in the yard and all their albums are
coming my way they weren't around oh you
know right right right right so to come
home and and be able to have the luxury
to work with them
um was dope you know what I'm saying it
was it was very encouraging yeah I knew
I was on something are you um as like an
independent artist
what are some of the things that you've
like uh learned over the last like four
or five years because I feel like when
you're independent sometimes you don't
have to like you don't have the luxury
of having a building behind you that
kind of already knows what not to do and
what to do you got to kind of like just
keep it moving when you when you yeah
you go through Growing Pains you got to
learn from your mistakes what are some
of the biggest things you've you've
learned so far the biggest thing that
well what I did this time that I came
home
um I try to rationalize my situation so
I tell myself all right there's no label
behind you no more
we're definitely trying to go back to
the pen for another 10. so what are we
gonna do you know what I'm saying right
I put myself in college
um for a year and I got myself into a
good field where I could generate enough
money to become my own labor you know
what I'm saying what field was that um
electrical I do electrical oh [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah so so you're an electrician
yes sir hell yeah wow that's fire yeah
so um so yeah so I put myself to college
like I said because in my experience
before
um I felt like other people were
dictating the path of my music and how I
was going the direction it was going in
or when I could do this or right studio
time for that matter
so um
I didn't feel like I didn't feel like
begging dog like like and I don't mean
begging like in the wrong way what I
mean is like I didn't want to put myself
in a vulner position and people be
looking at me like oh I'm A desperate
looking for help so
um I did my [ __ ] independently I funded
my own [ __ ] legitimately with with money
I was doing through my nine to fives and
long shifts I was pulling but at the
same time
um I have such a strong standing
reputation in streets that it wasn't
hard for me to like get direct lines to
so and so so right right right
um I've dealt with people from all from
Crips to Bloods to everything on the
streets before so um it wasn't hard for
me to connect those dots so I just
worked with what I had you know what I'm
saying right I took advantage of the the
pros that I did have and the cons I just
try to evolve them into some that could
become an advantage also you feel the
same I feel like most people would not
uh
yeah I feel like having a practical
trade to to have to fund your dream yeah
is like something that most people
wouldn't glorify well well I did it the
other way before
and it and you landed in prison
robberies and I did over a decade you
saw what the yeah you saw with the
downside yeah yeah reality was like yeah
you can be a risk taker but the risk
that we're taking
um [ __ ] or long-lasting Consequences and
so I didn't you know and then you come
home to your family you gotta think like
after a decade my dad died you know my
brother-in-law died my grandma died my
cousin died like [ __ ] the house was
empty you feel me so
I came home to a family in shambles like
women that didn't have no mail in the
house there was no uncle that loved the
nieces there was no dad that loved their
kids there was no right older brother to
look over my sister you feel I'm saying
so with that I put my ego in my practice
aside you feel I'm saying like I felt
like I had a bigger purpose you know
that's big man yeah I think like two
just for anybody watching like it's okay
to figure out well I think it's [ __ ] way
I think it's I think it's I think that
it's not okay not to do it legitimately
because as a business let's say you're
doing real estate bro right and you're
buying houses to flip and [ __ ] of course
but you're doing it off of illegitimate
money one day they're gonna trade one
day the paper trail is gonna come back
to you or or they're gonna catch you you
feel I'm saying you're just gonna get
caught out of red light without the
right blinker on and it's a wrap you
feel I'm saying so the margin of error
is [ __ ] well yeah and like you you
move around stress the [ __ ] yeah well I
did you know I mean like the homie will
tell you like they they came for me they
rated all my pads I had to [ __ ] flee
to Colorado with an advance from the
label I ended up burning the label for
their Advance on that they never got to
recoup off my [ __ ]
Universal okay [ __ ] so um so yeah so as
a business model it's it's not a good
model too you know what I mean to go and
I know a lot of people do it and I know
it's glorified
um in this business but I don't know bro
I just can't do it again you feel I'm
saying I'm not ready for that trip you
know yeah no that's too good more people
should uh preach what you're preaching
man hey [ __ ] A lot of people haven't
been through what I've been through
that's why they don't that's real if
they knew better they would they would
say better you feel I'm saying but they
don't would you say that uh because what
originally how much time are you facing
you said you got 35 to life 35 lives
because I'm a two I'm a three Striker
and I've been busted for other robberies
as a kid I grew up without a household
you know so I've had to survive
what it doesn't matter that red thing
don't matter it just it just mutes out
of the headphones
yeah yeah that's fine so that red button
only mutes the headphones
does that make sense yeah because you
heard it in the headphones yeah you're
good you're good all right I'm sorry so
you were supposed to do 35 because for
people who don't know in Cali they had
the three strikes yeah yeah three
strikes is that still is that still it
is when like let's say that
you gotta understand the law is like a
chain link fence you know it has many
different Loops directions and
connections and how it's bonded together
but when you're a DA and you really want
to prosecute some somebody
every single case log that has existed
for mankind is open to you you just got
to learn how to use it in a loophole you
know what I'm saying so let's say for
instance you're you've done
um you've been busted for charm
robberies and one sexual assault right
right
um
the law might say oh it's not all three
armed robberies so we can't strike them
out you know what I'm saying but the D.A
if they catch you for three sexual
assaults they'll find a way to be like
okay it's the exact same crime every
time he's like criminal yeah let's
strike them out on those streets so it
just depends now how bad the prosecution
wants you and what kind of case they
want you know so at what point in time
did you find out because once you get
put in 35 to life you're pretty much
like this is my life
um so I got I I went to trial I've
always went I've always gone to trial
because I have nothing to lose you know
when when you um have something to lose
like you tend to take a deal yeah but
with me they never offered me a date it
was always life life or 25 plus on to me
might as well be life so
um so I went to trial and um I lost in
trial in Pomona Court Superior Court
um judge Tia Fisher found me guilty of
all my charges except from assault with
a deadly weapon the shooting I beat
um but five armed robberies are
convicted of so um when she went you
know they so you get let's say today is
your day to find out your verdict you
get found guilty right right boom knock
you out go back to court come back in
two months for sentencing at that point
within those two months the law well the
judge the D.A either has the opportunity
to go through your file and try and give
you some leniency or they just don't
give a [ __ ] and give you the max time
right so a lot of times it depends on
your crime the seriousness of it the
violence behind it and really how it
went down to get some kind of sympathy
you know what I'm saying so um fortunate
for me the lawyer that I was going with
at the time
um really pushed for the judge to open
on my file
so two months after her verdict
um she gave me she gave me 18 years with
the probability of parole you know what
I'm saying so my case I was supposed to
get 35 to life but the judge um
basically told me look laws are changing
I'm gonna end up bringing you back 10
years anyways and land you go yeah she
wasn't lying to be honest with you yeah
like I went up with the 18 years from
the 18 years of church or 13 years from
13 to turn to 10 because of Prop 47 was
changing so many laws right Jerry Brown
the original person that wrote The Three
strike law came back because I don't
know if you know but California prisons
were so overflooded that Arnold
Schwarzenegger signed a state of
emergency which meant that we're so
populated we could start renting prisons
in other states and taking them so they
rented I think three prisons in Arizona
one in Oklahoma two in Mississippi
that's that prison that prison for
profit [ __ ] yes sir all federal
judges own that [ __ ] so you know if all
federal judges own the prisons
on the canteens and everything that
[ __ ] generates money in it how are
they not going to create a keep you in
prison yeah it's a hustle so um I ended
up from Centinela I ended up to Arizona
and then I went all the way to
Mississippi tallahatchee and then I came
back yeah [ __ ] yeah well we're getting
caught up in [ __ ] you know you think
that that was kind of like because of
the three strike thing hell yeah yeah
because they were giving people to well
because I was like California
specifically yeah yeah only it's an
enhancement you know it's an enhancement
but with the three strike law came a
gang of different enhancements you know
it wasn't just strikes like it was let's
say you you've been to prison before
they were giving you two extra for that
Jesus let's say
um it was gang involved that's automatic
10 to 15 extra years so there was a lot
of dudes Upstate that that their crime
only carried three years but they were
doing 18 off of enhancements
not actual crimes you know saying that
crimes that she had done in the past
things that didn't weren't even
prevalent in what you're robusted for
right now you know what I'm saying so
um as a loss changed my day changed and
it got to a point where I had been down
so long like just kick them out so I got
like I think a 10-day notice before I
came home oh [ __ ] yeah you didn't know
you were just like hell no I came home
[ __ ] up like like honestly
um emotionally mentally I wasn't
prepared right you know I was wired a
certain way you gotta understand like I
took so much loss while I was busted as
far as heartbreak and heartache like I
suffered yeah all kinds of people that
emotionally I wasn't I wasn't confident
bro like I was you know my spirit was
broke to a certain extent like I know
flight or fly I know how to survive
right I knew how to be heartless and
take care of business in there but I
didn't know how to digest some
my care for the world my care for my
life you know what I'm saying I lost
some application for my family I lost a
lot of [ __ ] I lost a lot so I went back
I came home and I was out like four
months oh you went back yeah I went back
bro I was out four months and then um I
broke some Fool's nose at a bar over
some stupid [ __ ] damn so I went back
again for four months and that's when
really like the humbling came you feel
I'm saying like that's when the moment
of reflection like like I told myself
like damn you're a grown ass man like
you ain't got [ __ ] to show for it um oh
you got a CDC numbers you feel me like
but you talk all this gangster [ __ ] like
to me gangsters ain't broke you know
yeah I also feel like people got to
start to understand like at a certain
point in time like if someone talks [ __ ]
to you at a bar yeah
like it's probably the more gangster
thing to be the bigger guy and just be
like you know what now I know now I'm
the type of [ __ ] like the minute
I see [ __ ] hey you want to drink bro I
got you the [ __ ] this man drinking you
know yeah or somebody bring the strip
over here give the boy a laptop he needs
to cool down you know what I'm saying
because I'm not afraid of what he's
gonna do I'm afraid of what I'm gonna do
bro like my consequences are coming yeah
well I know I got everything to lose so
when you got everything loose you
Playing for Keeps you feel what I'm
saying I'd rather I'd rather just you
know I mean like try to avoid this [ __ ]
dog because at this point like there's
no profit in it you know yeah I think
people got to understand like um
you can literally change your life just
making one mistake hell yeah you could
be drinking too much one decision dog
could cost you everything it costs you
everything everything literally you get
it you might get into a fight at a bar
and then you hit somebody and then they
fall and they hit their head look around
and then you're [ __ ] ninja over the
rest of your life picture this scenario
right you go to prison
and this happened to me that's why I'm
speaking you go to prison
and you know your Bae mom's at home with
the kid yep and you're fighting this
[ __ ] together and you're thinking
there's a bond right because you know we
tend to have that illusion we're busted
like people gonna ride it out with us or
people gonna be there for us one time I
called home
and literally the girl that I was being
with took the phone off the hook
accepted my call and put it on speaker
so that I could hear her getting my
little girl ready to go out for dinner
with another man oh
and then think about it like I'm gonna
be honest with you I stood there and I
heard the whole [ __ ] I couldn't hang up
like no matter how much ego and how much
pride and how much gangsterism is in me
I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't hang up
bro right you know what I'm saying but
those are the vulnerable positions you
put yourself when you're taking those
losses you feel what I'm saying and also
like to be honest like it's also
probably not fair to expect someone
exactly to wait for you that's the way
that because you you want you want hell
yeah you really love that girl let her
go you should allow her to go and
because you were facing even even if it
was 18 years right yeah it's like come
on like you kind of want to make it yeah
but it's but it that's that's what I'm
saying though it's an unrealistic
reality that we expect yeah you know
what I'm saying like our expectations
are way too pure for the filth that we
live in you know what I'm saying like we
expect [ __ ] to have honor and
not snitch we expect [ __ ] to
have honor and not run from a fight we
expect women to stay loyal even though
we were probably cheating on them
because I was cheating like a
[ __ ] when I was out right I was
cheating I wasn't coming home but
your arrogance makes you self and you
start to believe that you're entitled to
a lot of [ __ ] that you're not right you
know what I'm saying so when you go away
that's why I frown so much on people
snitching and debriefing because you
think you're doing something dog at the
time right you might think like oh you
you got the best of the system [ __ ]
everybody I'm getting out they weren't
gonna write for me anyways nah bro like
what you're missing is the lesson that
you're gonna get during that time you
were busted you know what I'm saying
like you're shortening yourself from
life experiences and virtues like only
on your own you can learn because
Solitude is the best teacher bro to find
out who you are to find out what you're
prepared for and to find out like
exactly how far you'll take something
like I knew in prison I couldn't do life
I admit that [ __ ] like I can't do life
dog I love [ __ ] I love my freedom you
know what I'm saying I like what comes
with providing I like living with a
purpose you know what I'm saying and
that was the biggest thing for me in
prison was like waking up
you're just staring at a wall dog no
opportunity no no nothing you're just a
empty shell of existence you feel I'm
saying like there's nothing bro nothing
yeah even writing letters felt stupid
after my eighth year I bet you know like
why the [ __ ] am I riding these people
let me write back don't give a [ __ ]
you're over here pouring your soul out
on a [ __ ] letter
and [ __ ] don't even open it
when it gets home and I'm in the same
place now like trust me all my homies
write me and this and that most time I
don't have time to write back or even
read them bro wow like I got to be on a
trip where it's two hours where I'm like
you know what the homie roaming let me
call his mom I'm gonna send her Zeal her
100 bucks for him and tell him I said my
love I can't write back yeah
[ __ ] call my phone all day I
don't got time to answer bro like I just
don't
know what I'm saying but that's the fact
that's the facts the world keeps turning
without you what up y'all we gotta stop
the interview to tell you about our new
sponsors our family at hardeen Las Vegas
you see what it is you see what it is
welcome to the family heart Dean man
we're so excited I've been going to
Hardy for so many years for people who
don't know Hardin is that premium
cannabis dispensary the number one
award-winning dispensary in Las Vegas
I'm talking the biggest and best
selection of cannabis products and of
course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're the [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to Jardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on the
bootleg cat podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to
hardinlasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n Las vegas.com and don't
forget when you go to Vegas you go to
Jardin tell them I sent you and then
only might throw a little extra little
eighth in the bag or something leave a
little discount the bootleg discount you
know what I'm saying get them packwoods
too they give me a Packwood the other
day that geez I'm still recovering from
that [ __ ] blew my whole [ __ ] face off
in the best way Hardy in Las Vegas all
right shout out to them let's get back
to the interview is the uh
is it still like letters that are
prevalent yes because I know they have
like um that's feds emails is feds okay
okay emails as fast yeah so if you're
just in a normal State Prison it's
normal yeah it's letters man it's still
old school you know because I don't like
stamps I know some people like have
iPads and [ __ ] yeah they got iPads but
the iPads are to download music so
they're like iPods you know what I'm
saying but the system allows you to do
educational [ __ ] on them too right if
you're like on certain Netflix is on
hell no they know I used to have porn in
the prison in the joint though video I
had everything I had an Xbox I had a
Sony boombox I had cell phones how do
you how do you all kinds of is that
isn't that technically controversial it
is but when they shipped us out of state
we were doing time according to
out-of-state rules so if you're in
Mississippi or in Arizona you have that
not cell phones right but you Xbox you
can have an Xbox hell yeah in your in
yourself hell yeah so you're able to
play like Halo XBox 360. I was on death
space all day you're playing dead space
Modern Warfare one Modern Warfare two
like I got every perv every wow okay
California they don't allow that no hell
no California everything's see-through
bro like like this in California you got
to be able to see what what state did
you have the Xbox in
um Arizona that's where I originally
bought it I bought in Arizona but it
traveled with me all the way to
Mississippi and Mississippi when I came
back I left it to the homies you know so
when you go to those out of state places
uh
do the California politics Follow You
Hell Yeah mandatory we open up the
prison so we got to establish that right
just to avoid like look there's a
misconception of prison politics you
know like I know a lot of people have
come here and like try and make it sound
like it's a racial thing to be honest
with you like that's farthest from the
truth you know and my homeboy will tell
you like he was with me in the yard like
right we're doing everything together
but
it's a necessary evil in prison bro like
you gotta understand right let's say me
and you are on some thorough hood [ __ ]
right and we're in prison you know
there's a gang of smokers that are there
with us you know not it's not just
thorough foods that go to prison and you
know there's also crack kids there's
also dummies drunks right all kinds of
[ __ ] right
now when you're dealing with those type
of individuals they don't know the
structure that we know right like
respect right they don't know how to
like move accordingly so the prison
politics are a necessary evil to stop
race racial issues to real escalating
you know what I'm saying like hey that's
the phone for your people that's the
shower for your people that's the
basketball court for you guys so guess
what you'll never gotta fight with
somebody over hey I got next game and
it's a different race and then [ __ ]
we're all going to the hole you know
what I'm saying or it's it's kind of
like necessary to keep as much Harmony
as possible until there's not Harmony
until there's not right you know what
I'm saying but but it's not it's not
because oh we hate them nah it's not
even like that bro it's just to keep a
structure because you're in chaos all
the time I don't know bro I remember
when I would land to prisons right like
when you first get off the bus no
[ __ ] I remember when I got to
Centinel the three yard and I landed in
the lifer building
um because I was on close custody
because I had so much time so when
you're in close custody the first 15
years of your of your term you only get
two hours of program a day that's the
only time you get to come out so it's
two hours wow so I was in close custody
pretty much solitary that ain't [ __ ] an
extra hour yeah so um
so I land on the life for building to be
on close custody and I sat on the bench
and this Asian dude's [ __ ] yelling at
me from the door like welcome to Santa
hella because the prison is called
Centinela you know but like
there is no like how can you say it
don't let there's no there's no chance
to ever like think peacefully there you
know even if you're on your own peaceful
Journey like the noises around you are
always chaos oh they're always yeah yeah
somebody's always stirring the pop bro
it doesn't matter there's an idiot in
there yeah always somebody discouraging
you always like even when you're trying
to go home like what you getting ready
to go home for you just gonna come back
like what the [ __ ] they ain't going
[ __ ] mad you know what I'm
saying so so it's like all that rules
and all the structure is to create some
kind of normality you know what I'm
saying who's the most interesting person
you were locked up with Lyfe Jennings
just shared he was locked up with
Jeffrey Dahmer I was busted with um well
I I ran into uh I ran into a few rappers
like that I looked at looked up to um I
run into um
um Drew down yeah for the year man yeah
he was in Susanville I ran to Drew down
I ran to um sugar-free I ran into
um goldilock but the most interesting
one that I ran into was a porn star out
of the valley right here his name was
Philip Oliver his poor name was oh I
don't know but anyways he he was a porn
star and like his stories were just the
best
stories yeah you know what I'm saying so
to me he was the most interesting
because everybody else I could relate I
heard all that [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying but this fool is a beast you know
what I'm saying he was Legend out here
sugar-free had to be I mean he's a cool
sugarfield was a trip but he wasn't
talking to us like right like what you
see on the streets that's not how he is
in there you know I don't know if
because you know he's he's sober or what
it is you know what I'm saying but he's
just different 100 uh so you obviously
you get out you go back you get out
again you're [ __ ] you you finally
kind of have your mind right yeah
um when how long between the second time
you got out
um
Before You released your first music
um [ __ ] I started recording right away
so what I was doing at the beginning was
doing the SoundCloud [ __ ] okay like I
had given myself a goal because I
couldn't afford too much studio time
um I would go record one song a week and
give it away free I couldn't afford to
buy Beats or engineering right so I had
found this this
um relative of art well through my niece
her boyfriend's cousin he could engineer
so uh some uh so I used to go record and
then I would upload one song a week to
um to SoundCloud and YouTube you know
and um I would just try and see what it
did what it did and then little by
little
um I met somebody that told me you know
what I'll help you put out a whole
independent project like don't you ain't
got to pay me [ __ ] I just want to see
you win so we did that and after that
that's when I really like once I put
something together like a real project
I've seen like people really getting
behind it what year was that that was
2016. okay yeah 2016. but I was doing
shows at bars and like that [ __ ] would
fill out you know what I'm saying so um
like little bar programs like come
through again you know so that [ __ ] was
encouraging you know what I'm saying but
it was tough though at the beginning dog
because like I said I was doing it
legitimately yeah so you remember when
when like Foose first started shooting
videos they weren't cheap like they are
now right yeah yeah
when the independent shooters were
coming out they were you know because
now you can get a video done for like
300 yeah so if you find like a young kid
with a camera and Final Cut yeah hell
yeah yeah 250 300 bucks all day you know
I mean and it looks dope you know what
I'm saying so back then [ __ ]
were charging their arm and a leg so I
used to I used to borrow money from my
sister I used to borrow money from my
sister to keep um gas in my car to go to
school you know what I'm saying get back
and forth and then pay for my studio
time my video you know what I mean I
would pay her back I probably still owe
her money who [ __ ] knows but you know
what I'm saying like the sis was helping
me out you know I mean like the sis my
homies from my hood yeah Mommy's from my
hood were um were helping me with that I
had one of my homies rest in peace Mojo
I just lost Tim like less than a year
ago he built me a studio like oh [ __ ] we
had a carport
and my homie [ __ ] he was one of them
you know eight in the morning to eight
at night like I still didn't sleep he
built me one you know what I'm saying
and that's when like I started feeling
like okay I really gotta do this [ __ ]
like yeah people are kind of investing
in you yeah yeah most definitely yeah so
all that help was like very encouraging
and it was good for my confidence you
feel I'm saying tell me uh about the day
you guys went to no jumper with American
cholo because there's a lot a lot of
guys a lot of the homies came with you
yeah yeah uh yeah but that's the thing
like look man and I know you have a
great relationship with A.D yeah and um
you guys obviously have music together
and you guys have a a a strong bond but
uh just what was the um the thought
process of just bringing a bunch of
bunch of fools with you because it was a
lot of people yeah yeah we went we went
deep as [ __ ] um and honestly bro it was
this dog like like
in our community our elders are are very
much respected you know what I'm saying
I would hope that in every Community but
in ours of course in ours though we we
do like really listen I have a Mexican
wife yeah a Mexican baby mama yeah yeah
so you know 100 yeah so so when Gil was
getting attacked I saw it you know what
I'm saying I saw it and I knew the
history behind it so I could stand
behind them you know what I'm saying you
knew the context yeah I knew I knew the
context exactly how it was right so um
he calls me and I could hear it in his
voice that he's looking for some kind of
like like I don't want to say help
because I don't want to make him sound
weak but he was looking for a friend dog
you feel I'm saying somebody to stand
beside him that that had a validity out
here that can really speak up on [ __ ]
that's been there done that so um I
didn't even let him ask me I just told
him like Hey bro you want me to go with
you and he was like yeah you know so
then I saw it as an opportunity to bring
a lot of homies together like what
people don't understand bro is like yeah
we came deep and and there was all
homies but I had a lot of rival gangs
there that aren't supposed to be
together so you kind of brought some
people hell yeah like the homies came
together without question nobody nobody
ever also before I get to that yeah so
you know I asked them like yo I'm gonna
go with you he's like yeah if you're not
busy like pull up
so I hang up I told no doubt I'll be
there with you I hang up and then I'm
sitting at I'm just sitting in my living
room and I'm like you know what like I
saw it as an important moment for us as
a community you feel I'm saying I saw it
as as a as a
good moment to communicate to people how
blackballed we are in the industry
mainstream you know like Power 106 took
down the interview without even no
question you know what I'm saying like
it was quick um Adam for whatever reason
was motivated to put up that post you
know what I'm saying and then now
one of our elders that has a positive
voice in our community whether you
believe in what he says or not he's not
bringing nothing negative on the
community you know what I'm saying he's
not making our people look
um unruly or uneducated you know what
I'm saying so
when that was that question I just
thought to myself like you know what
this is a good opportunity for us to
show solidarity you know I mean Unity
you know what I'm saying because
everybody's always you had just I had
just heard whack one whack 100 all over
the place talking about how you know the
Southsiders ain't
um they don't have control their own
destiny you know they got to do what
they're told and we're like this [ __ ]
hit squad bro that that just follows a
dictator you know what I'm saying so um
I started reaching out to people
and then I called Gil like hey bro like
you you wanna you feel like going deep
and he was like you know I think we
should right so I was like [ __ ] it so I
reached out to a gang of homies for
different hoods and not once did anybody
um asked me like hey who's gonna be
there or you know like who and it was
just because people felt the same way we
felt you know I'm saying like just
because we're not on IG or on YouTube
run our mouth about Brown lives matter
or or this and that or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it right doesn't mean
we don't have an opinion or feelings
about how we're being represented you
know what I'm saying
so I threw it out there to the homies
honestly I'm not going to take credit
for that [ __ ] like I might have invited
20. the other 80 came on their own
through Word of Mouth you feel what I'm
saying then people started calling me
and hey what's going on we'll pull up
you know what I'm saying if you see the
whole footage
um dog we didn't force our way in there
right [ __ ] ads been with me with like
50 cholos before by himself in the hood
you know what I'm saying so A.D was like
Kylie like come in you know what I mean
like come on let's all come in we all
here together because to A.D he don't
see a bunch of Mexican cholos he just
he's the homies yeah you know what I
mean those hey that's the squad both of
them come on you know you know it's so
interesting because I thought that the
interview you guys did was though
because it was at a time when I felt
like
the unity of black and brown people in
in Cali in La needed to be kind of
Illustrated yeah and I feel like you and
aed's conversation yeah but that's what
happens when when you get like two real
Street dudes and I gotta be honest with
you like I had no idea like until maybe
like I've been out here since 2017 and
um
I didn't understand like the I didn't I
wasn't raised out here so I don't know
the like the history between the black
and brown Community historically in La
is like a pretty divisive one yeah it is
because in Arizona where I'm from the
blacks and the Mexicans my whole life
have just been homies yeah you know I
grew up definitely yeah I grew up in a
heavily Mexican area all my best friends
are Black or Mexican and everybody
always got along yeah
um so you know I know that there was
like a few things that had kind of led
up to you guys during that interview and
um you know I felt like a necessary
moment to have with A.D and you and you
know him and and uh you know I think I
think it it didn't to me it didn't feel
like to me it was a representation like
if look dog I don't just see things for
the layer that is presented to you you
know right I always see things in layers
I see things like from 110 to 2 10s to
three tens you know I mean everything
comes with fractions you know what I'm
saying and if you see the fractions of
that day bro like
it's clear as day you know what I'm
saying um there's people that only give
a [ __ ] about views and ratings and
there's people that give a [ __ ] about
The Human Side you know there's people
that are currently living in a virtual
world and there's people that still live
in reality you feel insane so but I
think it's important for like La I
believe
like a few other major cities are one of
the cities that can dictate how things
are presented and move forward you know
what I'm saying according to how we move
as a society other states follow you
feel what I'm saying so um I think that
mutual respect towards each other even
the way even from what I told Adam was
like look bro like just learn how we
move you know what I'm saying and then
you can move correctly and not worry
about 100 [ __ ] coming to your
spot and telling you what the [ __ ] you
did wrong even though it's common sense
you know what I'm saying but let's just
get if like you could play with anybody
else don't play with us you know what
I'm saying like move how you want to
move with other people and other groups
or whatever but when it comes to like
what we represent like move move
carefully dog because
we see things in different light you
know I'm saying what you might not think
is disrespectful to us is extremely and
what much and the opposite you know what
I'm saying so um it was a good day I
think it was dope um Adam wasn't there
which I to this day think is [ __ ] up
you know what I'm saying like him being
there would have just made it
um
more like transparent that that there is
no [ __ ] you feel I'm saying that
there wasn't no ill intentions right
there was no sabotage you know what I'm
saying
um you know how it is when you want to
defend yourself you got to get face you
know what I'm saying so I think that we
went there to get face and and A.D and
dunno's pulled up and it was cool but
like you know now it's becoming a point
where like it's a stabbing point though
like any little chance they get they
bring it up again you know or somebody
will bring it up or they're asking
Swifty about it and Swifty's talking
about well you ain't you know come on
bro like at the end of the day bro like
it's not about you or me you know what
I'm saying it's about the community the
streets and the [ __ ] that can happen
after we leave the studio and we go home
to our comfortable [ __ ] paths right
because most of us ain't posted on in
the on the Block no more like we used to
be right if we did we wouldn't have the
opportunities that we have so I think
that we have to hold ourselves
responsible for the people that we still
got on the Block you know what I mean
yo it's bootleg Kev here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture all my guys
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you 200 on top of that to gamble
with for free if you put in a thousand
dollars they're gonna match that deposit
with a free thousand dollars for you to
gamble with right now so what the [ __ ]
are you waiting for let's get this money
let's watch some [ __ ] football and
let's get paid with my bookie yeah what
because like obviously you just brought
up Swifty I wasn't gonna bring him up
but you brought him up so [ __ ] it um
you know I know you guys not seen eye to
eye yeah
um online you know he's a lot younger on
everything we don't see I don't know
he's obviously a lot he's a lot younger
than you yeah you know what I mean he's
probably
uh in a place in his life that when you
were in in his shoes probably when you
were younger you were probably you
probably didn't have the knowledge or
the wisdom that you currently have
have you have you considered like
reaching out to him on some positive
[ __ ] well I'm strategic with everything
that I do right because I know because I
know you guys have had words for each
other I know the important speech behind
my moves you feel I'm saying so um to me
right now my silence is golden you feel
what I'm saying it's like
at you you at home right you have kids
right of course you ain't gonna argue
with your kids right right there it is
there yeah you know what I'm saying it's
that simple I have to carry myself like
a man and he has to carry himself like a
young man no I'm doing my part now does
he live up to his own expectations we're
gonna see yeah you know what I'm saying
ain't no need to even run our mouths no
more like and and it's exactly like what
you said it's just the age difference
though you feel what I'm saying I
realize that you know what I mean that's
another reason why I'm not like
persistently going after certain topics
and certain people because at my age dog
I have to carry myself like I have the
knowledge the wisdom the importance and
the receipts to back up the way that I
move without having to talk yeah I don't
really got to run my mouth like just my
presence says it by itself you know what
I'm saying you know we always have heard
like uh in certain cities the checking
in thing and obviously he's gone viral
and he's got his check-in website which
is a great marketing idea I [ __ ] love
it you get a certificate on it yeah but
like in terms of like um
do you think that's something that's
important if someone comes to LA I have
to tap in with like certain aspects
that's important anywhere you're at
right you know like like how does the
same how's the saying go one of the
oldest things right when in Rome
you do as a Romans do you feel me that's
that's my thing is is like I always you
know it depends but it's a thing if
you're a street rapper exactly yes let's
say you could be you could be from
Chicago absolutely and if you move as
like a a street rapper you you claim to
be from the streets yeah it's probably
smart for YouTube hell yeah
that's what you're going to attract if
you're like a pop artist yeah you come
to L.A yeah do your [ __ ] do your thing
yeah yeah you might get robbed but you
know what I'm saying yeah but wasn't
nobody gonna defend you anyways at that
point it's like you know it's like I
feel like I do feel like if you're if
you represent that if you're bringing
that energy then yeah you gotta and
that's wherever you go right everyone
have some homies where everywhere oh
yeah [ __ ] hell yeah it's it's it's it's
just Safety First you know what I'm
saying why wouldn't you like why not why
not pay homage and and want to meet the
people where you're where you're coming
to you know what I'm saying why not meet
the locals you know what I'm saying and
learn the rules of the land dog at the
end of the day it's only going to
benefit you and get more love if
anything yeah you know what I'm saying
so yeah it's important I think it's
table manners you know where everywhere
you go you gotta have table manners
though you got to present yourself well
what do you think of like um just kind
of like the influx in you know we lost
pnb rock out here
um which by the way after finding out
that it was like a father's father-son
yeah yeah that shit's crazy well that's
the moment of reflection I think
I think it's a moment to like like see
the layers behind the action itself
right like you got literally
Father and Son Duo come in a crime that
cost the life of a successful young man
you feel what I'm saying and um and from
what I heard I think the kid had an
ankle monitor on and he was like yeah
some [ __ ] like that yeah but what I'm
saying is this like it's it's a like
this is what's happening bro and I see
it a lot in my in my in my community
right like
there's men right now that are so caught
up with social media and this lifestyle
that it brings right that they're trying
to hang with the kids
you know what I'm saying like there's no
there's no division in in clout is a
hell of a drug that's what I'm saying
right so we gotta we gotta look at
ourselves like
I see it as a failure in the men you
know I mean the men that are here right
now like ain't moving like men are
supposed to move we're not supposed to
be following the little homies or even
trying to be the little homies you know
what I'm saying there's an art form to
being a big homie yeah you know what I
mean like the art form is like you've
been through the [ __ ] so teach the
little homies better you feel what I'm
saying but right now you got a lot of
grown men trying to be little man
youngsters you feel what I mean big
homies doing little homies [ __ ] yeah so
so but that's what social media does bro
like you understand a lot of
[ __ ] like didn't even have
names or reputations before social media
you know before you really had to come
outside like if [ __ ] knew your
dog you was literally outside 24 7. yeah
you never went away and when you went to
jail you hit the block as soon as you
got out and you were hitting that
[ __ ] Street like there was no
and when you were in The Joint you were
raising your hand for every Mission like
that's how you that was social media
before was Stripes no I mean but now
we're in this virtual world dog where
you know what I mean you can make up
your you know what I'm saying and and a
lot of men that have
um what's the word I'm looking for that
have um confidence problems are looking
at that to validate who they are as men
you know saying you can't because social
media is mostly for children I think you
know I mean I think that only children
are allowed to live in their imagination
right I think that grown-ups live in
reality well they have to yeah right
because we we have obligations it feels
to pay man hell yeah you got buildings
to build you know we got to keep this
[ __ ] going you know what I'm saying like
so I think that um as a community that's
where we're at like not only a community
just in general bro because you see even
older women trying to act like they're
young like twerking again the bbls and
and like you know what I'm saying like
yeah it's wild I see 40 year old women
talk about my N word this my n-word that
like girl like you you were just super
this [ __ ] for the last 30 years of
your life you know I mean like so we
have identity crisis going on right now
you know what I'm saying and I think
that um as man we gotta act like it dog
because dog imagine that dog like a
father and son like shit's wife that's
like that that would be like [ __ ] I
couldn't even see myself telling my son
like hey grab the burner we're about to
go rob something drop old boy for all
his [ __ ] jewelry it's crazy and the
fact it was like I think that just
reading the details of like what
actually happened you're like damn that
kid was 17 and decided to like
consciously like not just Rob him like
Rob him and then put him down well
there's more layers said think about
that think about what his dad is
communicating to when they're at home
the example that his father's giving him
it's [ __ ] I ain't talking about
bodies around my little boy bro
what the [ __ ] like we talk sports if
anything and kid probably that kid
probably had a terrible life hell yeah
for sure if we check his record I'm sure
he's been out of jail you know custody
issues you know what I'm saying like all
that [ __ ] that comes with his soul I
mean look bro I think that it's crazy
that
let's say for instance it would have
been a cop killing a a young black man
or a Hispanic man right or marching
right and we're doing all this [ __ ] and
we're there's awareness and we need to
be heard but when it's us failing us
nobody wants to talk about it right it's
almost like a hidden secret dirty secret
in the family you know we're not allowed
to talk about it why the [ __ ] not this
is when we really gotta address these
shits because at home is the root of all
the rest of the problems 100 in your
world so if we can stop that we can stop
a lot of other [ __ ] yeah but we don't
ever you know we're quick to point the
finger at everybody else yeah broken
homes man have a lot to do with them
yeah that's my you know I I grew up in a
great family once my mom died from
cancer it was a wrap well you said that
you kind of grew up without a household
yeah well I lost my mom when I was 12 um
13 my mom died from um pancreatic cancer
my dad lost custody of me like within
six months of that I became aware of the
state at the age of 14. so you're just
bouncing around yes sir yeah damn yeah
yeah so you know like [ __ ] I mean
teach his own bro but you know I know I
know the reality of this [ __ ] that comes
with it you feel I'm saying and you know
I move like I move a certain way so but
I understand but I'm willing to the
consequence I'm going to deal with you
know what I'm saying and which ones I'm
not you know what I mean
you were talking uh we're talking a
little bit off camera just kind of about
like uh Mexicans and Hip-Hop yeah and uh
obviously there's I feel like um
the landscape of Mexican hip-hop isn't
the best place it's ever been yeah for
sure hell yeah um yeah because I've seen
both eras you know right I was like I
remember like when I first like
obviously growing up in Arizona we have
MC Magic we go to the Lowrider show it
was always at them off of Tucson yeah we
were doing all them shows [ __ ] high
power records yeah I was on stage with
them and uh and uh you know little Rob
and [ __ ] brown boy and all these guys
shout out a little Uno all these guys
and uh it was big over there it was huge
huge but it was like an extreme it was
it was literal Chicano rap hell yeah and
it was packed thousands of people
thousands hell yeah right and so like it
was like I always would like Little Rob
I think was probably one of the only
quote-unquote Chicano rappers because I
don't consider MC Magic that because I
think he just makes love music that
[ __ ] love
um yeah he's he's auto-tune singer
before auto-tune singers were popular
right he's a voice box guy yeah after
Roger Troutman hey what up y'all it's
bootleg Kev here to stop the interview
sorry uh but we gotta pay the [ __ ]
bills and you know not only do we have
to pay the bills but we also gotta take
care of them [ __ ] out there that's
right make sure you go to bluetooth.com
right now you know the bootleg kept
podcast we are presented by bluetooth
proudly I happen to every once in a
while dabble in a little chooski you
know what I'm saying and let me tell you
something my dick thanks me for it every
single time uh so listen if you go to
Bluetooth use the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month supply
for free now we're talking the same
active ingredient as Viagra as Cialis
without the awkward doctor's appointment
visit you just go online they get you
taken care of it gets delivered right to
your [ __ ] door in discreet packaging
it's a beautiful thing and how about
this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and stacksin
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
to be a better jerk I'll tell you that
all right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground raps
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue too you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole something all
night long bluetooth.com use that promo
code bootleg right now and they will
give you the first month for free so go
do that [ __ ] um but little Rob had like
records that we played on the radio like
hits you know what I mean Around the
Clock yeah and so
um after him I felt like uh there was a
few records Big Gemini had a cool joint
um but I felt like there's kind of been
like once that era kind of dried out
it was kind of like dry I feel like
commercially for a lot of Mexican
hip-hop and now I mean look we talked
about King Lil G kind of held that flag
first a long time now there's so many
artists yes
um there's artists like a guy like cap G
yeah you know there's a guy who's from
Atlanta
um there's suede there's pesos
from Houston Man Gangnam like we're
killing it dog but what's always
happened with us is this bro like we're
misrepresented either in the business
side right or or were misrepresented on
the streets you know what I'm saying and
what I mean by like the first era we're
talking about Lil Robin on them right it
was exploited the cholo whole look was
exploited to you couldn't [ __ ] even
sell it no more like Kosh was giving out
deals to just anybody you know what I
mean so you would go to that's where you
got your deal right yeah so you would go
to Target [ __ ] that was like 50
different Mexican cholos on the shelves
like you didn't even know what to pick
up and it wasn't based on Talent they
were just giving deals on looks because
they don't they don't they didn't know
how to calibrate our talent right or
what we like you know what I'm saying
um
so then that happened the oversaturation
of the cholo cholo cholo to where it
ended up becoming almost like a mockery
you feel I'm saying it became it became
a joke you know what I'm saying um
because we evolved in the streets but as
far as like on the covers of CDs and
music we weren't right right because
they weren't letting no Talent new
talent in you feel insane because all
them cholos that they signed a lot of
them were hating on the rest you gotta
understand at that era we were still set
tripping each other like crazy so there
was a lot of Street politics I wasn't
allow oh homie's dough Ball but he from
18 we can't [ __ ] with him our homies
from White fans we can't [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying like there was a lot of
that going on
that's the biggest change that I noticed
this time I came home like the set
tripping amongst us in the business
wasn't as big but then what I saw was
this like
we had such a complex
from sounding like Chicano rappers that
at this point we became the exploiters
of the Black Culture by trying to sound
too black you feel what I'm saying so
it's like like Nipsey said in the album
you get abuse along enough you become
the abuser we start abusing the game you
feel what I'm saying now
we're looking for an identity and yeah
there's a gang of homies with Talent
right coming up coming up coming up [ __ ]
shout out to burner too yeah I mean to
be honest berner's probably the most
yeah successful Mexican rappers yeah
yeah I mean [ __ ]
um so yeah so now you get at this point
right and the little homies
are being raised by IG right and what
does IG mainly put out there like the
Black Culture they're exploiting I just
exploring the [ __ ] out of the Black
Culture to the fullest extent yeah
without Black Culture all these social
media platforms ain't [ __ ] would be you
know I mean but they're exploiting them
in the wrong way to me I think you know
I'm saying there is no highlighting
educated black man there is no
highlighting men black men that raise
families that are pillars in their
Community you know what I'm saying the
ones that do they're getting laid out
every single one is getting laid out you
know I mean like smoke you know yeah the
[ __ ] that goes viral is always the [ __ ]
that's like okay we get it like some of
these Instagram Pages really just focus
on like
the drama the craziest [ __ ] dog and what
it and what they don't realize is that
social media is Raising this next
Generation right you feel I'm saying
literally their rate they're raising the
youth you know because they have more
influence from the phone than even their
own parents right you know what I'm
saying
um so now that's where we're at and I
was just having this conversation
earlier with drummer boy shout out
drummer boy he's another one you know I
have to far from this [ __ ] he's from uh
Pomona yeah yeah so the homie's telling
me like he he literally asked me the
same [ __ ] but a different context he's
like how do you feel about where we're
at right now and I'm like dog like right
now we gotta fight for identity as a
culture because if we don't
what's going to happen is we're going to
be coming to Houston
and and I don't mean that and no
disrespectful way but the Hispanics in
Houston
have adapted the Black Culture
completely to where you can't really
tell the difference between
a Mexican rapper and a black rapper do
you think it's
a subject matter thing I know I just
think that I just think that
man you don't really want to know what I
think dog cause it's gonna sound ugly
yeah
but I think it comes with a type of
submission bro you know what I'm saying
like they gave up on trying to represent
the culture in its purest form you know
what I mean so they just kind of like
you know what this is how we gonna get
on
like I could I could I could easily say
the n-word in every song right now right
and I'll probably do better numbers
I could probably go braids my dog and
start doing you know what I'm saying
like
because that's where we're at right now
you know I'm saying everybody imitating
the Black Culture right without no
regard for their culture no regard for
their lineage no regard for their blood
and no regard for their history yeah I
think like it also depends on where you
were raised because I look at a guy like
that's [ __ ] no no no but listen but
listen now I was gonna say I look at a
guy like Captain in certain I look like
a guy like cap G who's never I've never
heard him say the N word yeah when you
listen to cap G he was raised in Atlanta
right yeah so like a lot of his music
sounds like Atlanta you know what I'm
saying but then he'll have other records
that have a lot of heavy like he has a
day without a Mexican which was a
[ __ ] Banger so I think cap G has done
a really good job of like balancing I'm
a dude who grew up where I grew up I'm
from Atlanta which is like yeah in my
opinion the capital of like hip-hop
culture now you know yeah most
definitely yeah I think cap G has done a
great job of life so then why don't we
see a lot more blacks trying to be
Mexican that grew up that grew up around
Mexicans
I don't I mean [ __ ] okay that's the
proof in the pudding to me you feel what
I'm saying it's like what's the biggest
form of humility
imitation yeah okay then you feel what
I'm saying and I'm not I mean and hey
well listen listen talk to me let's go
there have been a lot of artists I hate
to beat the tiger horse dead yeah but
listen but they but they the way they do
it is very strategically Smart Bro and
then I know YG just put a record out
with cucko yeah so like I think that
there has been and I think that like
but it's a small [ __ ] number true but
those guys grew up in La yeah YG signed
uh Savoy Loco you know why do dresses
like us for the most part he's got the
Stacy Adams he's got the last of his
head his whole [ __ ] everything like the
homies I think I think YG has been
somebody who obviously grew up around
Mexicans and in my opinion at least yeah
has paid homage Tastefully hell yeah I
think look honestly for whatever people
say about YG how they say it like I
think that he comes off sincere when he
feels like he has sincere love that's
what I'm saying like of course I grew up
in that tiger [ __ ] I'm sorry that didn't
come off sincere at all you know I mean
that was like it would and listen all
much love to that and that [ __ ] is old
as [ __ ] yeah he took the video down yeah
it's great like all up to him at the
table you know cool but it did it didn't
come up it came off it didn't come off
whoever was behind him right failed
right right you know what I'm saying but
you know like that's just the way I see
it you know what I'm saying like that's
the way I see it and um it's about to do
another shift like it's about to do
another shift like if you hit the block
right now there's no more skinny jeans
duh the little homies are dressing like
me now again right yt's and 501s all day
I think well I think two the other thing
we got to talk about is like obviously
hip-hop is Black Culture first most
definitely so I think well I would say
that it's white and black culture I
think it's black and I I know a lot of
people and Puerto Ricans black nah I'm
gonna tell you why I say that though why
do you say why Beastie Boys is [ __ ] you
mean one of the first hip-hop groups
ever yeah but the first no you're right
you're right you're right wrong but that
was like 84. I understand it wasn't like
at the roots but I'm saying when it
mattered
come on it was a bunch of white boys
from right here I think I think it's
you know if we go back to like you know
79 81 and Puerto Ricans and black yeah
you know what I mean it came for sure
over there yeah the mecca right like
right original hell yeah most definitely
but
when it took the stage and it was really
time to make it a business
it was the Beastie Boys and it was all
Cool J Beastie Boys Grand Master Flash
right now see what I'm saying so you
know I mean
that's not how I feel I'm just going by
what I saw growing up because I'm a huge
hip-hop fan you know what I'm saying but
um but there's beef over that too like
people like man who gives a [ __ ] dog I
believe like look dog
how do you create something there's the
people that build it and there's the
people that fund the building we funded
the building so how are we not a part of
it if we didn't believe in it and push
hip-hop the creation of it and stand
behind it it would have never took off
the way it did I mean and I mean all of
us I think but I think like the answer
to what you were asking like why don't
people imitating what we're doing I
think if you like one black culture is
the number one most influential culture
in in in the US yeah yeah and you could
say it has been Asia everywhere in the
world hell yeah and Hip-Hop culture
hip-hop is the number one genre of music
in the world that's that's a fact a fact
so hip-hop's the number one genre of
music
and it's it's it's derived from Black
Culture it is it is Black Culture you
know what I'm saying so I think that
that and black culture is the most
influential culture in the country
period like that's no debate yeah no
debate yeah like fashion you go to h m
you go that's all right yeah 100 so I
think that that's probably a little bit
more closer to like why you were it's
like yeah well why is nobody imitating
what we're doing and I do think that
obviously like there's very small
examples where people okay homage to
them I hear that part of the argument
and I've thought about that part of the
argument okay but then when I see rap
videos
low riders well especially on the west
coast you know what I was going to say
would you consider I mean because to me
no writing is us that's us 100 oh yeah
but you think about you know Dr Dre
Snoop Dogg oh hell yeah they adopted him
100 yeah but they did it right though
we didn't say that they did it in a way
that they paid homage hell yeah they did
a cloud they did it with class yeah you
know what I'm saying they they
represented they they they because
really low riders is is is is obviously
a Mexican thing but it's a la thing it's
a la thing yeah yeah start on the east
side yeah yeah but um I think that the
way they did it was um they showed like
the the the parts they should highlight
like the dope [ __ ] that we do you know
what I'm saying nah you know goofy [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying or
[ __ ] dressed like Mariachis
like we don't we're not out here dressed
like we're at you know what I'm saying
like I mean let's just be real you feel
I'm saying I get it's a part of culture
huge part of culture but I never seen
one of my homies on the Block dressed
like a mariachi Mariachi say it right
like I'm talking like you know what I
mean like I don't know no better but you
know what I'm saying so I mean I don't
know I'm I'm just a person that goes by
facts and I like I like honesty so I'm
saying so if I'm gonna be honest like I
see a lot of [ __ ] that um that isn't
necessarily fair but it is what it is
dog like at this point
um you know we're either gonna where
they're gonna rise from this with our
own Foundation our own structure or
we're just going to become a part of the
rest of the machine you know what I'm
saying so it's on us I think at that
part and that's what I was talking to
Drummer Boy about like I told him like
look bro like this is your time
like what you guys do at this moment is
going to Define
our people in the game for a while you
know I mean because right now like as a
people in this music game we're
searching for an identity you know what
I'm saying we really are like I was
talking to him earlier about the way
that he creates music you know and I was
telling him the same [ __ ] like bro if
you look different and you're a
different ethnicity you should be
through the roof right now bro yeah but
you got to fight the stigma you know
what I'm saying so do you fight the
stigma do you because hip-hop don't love
us for whatever it's worth we love
hip-hop but hip-hop don't love us at all
you know what I'm saying so are you
gonna stay in a toxic relationship or
are you going to move on and find a new
Breezy and make your family you know you
know what I really think it is man
I think
there has to be an honest conversation
where we're like
who's the who's the Mexican rapper that
you feel like
was on the same level as Drake or Jay-Z
or there hasn't been one ever so that's
what I'm saying yeah it's gonna take
that guy but why though hasn't there
been one I mean it's gonna take that guy
in the past yeah where you're like
there's somebody that's so dope it's
undeniable yeah so to me it's like
there's been a lot of cool like cool
dope Mexican artists but has there been
one that's so crazy that that it's just
undeniable whether it's
ability look at the one that they hit
records the one that they did blow up
for who no Talent on I mean six nine bro
the one that they did blow up like come
on bro like okay okay so so and I don't
want to get into this nation thing
because that's been yeah that's besides
six nine yeah yeah had records
he had undeniable records okay so it
didn't matter if he was like very
deniable how come La wasn't jamming them
all crazy in the clubs they were the
club says isn't the streets though bro
yeah the club is one stream I'm talking
about I'm talking about 2018 it's nice
who wasn't playing that [ __ ] on the
Block everybody okay then let's go more
relevant when um YG dropped My Crazy
Life who in the [ __ ] wasn't playing that
[ __ ] out here everybody everybody
everybody that's everywhere because I
travel everywhere people are playing all
right six nine wasn't booming like that
I don't know man I think a lot of those
numbers see to me the six nine [ __ ] was
to me a perfect example of somebody who
just made records that like were kind of
undeniable so it didn't really matter
that he was a clown and this is before
he snitched yeah of course yeah when
this [ __ ] was moving and we had that
conversation where I was like
artists gotta like
happen to be Mexican but be dope first
yeah and I think six nine
six nine people were like oh he's got
some gumbo and all that [ __ ] was for
them shits were hard the Nikki record
was hard and he happened to be a Mexican
guy yeah does that make sense yeah it
does yeah it does so I think like he had
records what was he but was he we're
under I think he had no but was he
representing the culture
I think he was representing his culture
how he grew up maybe does that make
sense I don't know yeah I could be I
don't know yeah you know what I'm saying
but
[ __ ] I think that I think I think that
that but that's an example of what I was
saying like yeah Who's the artist that
like is making undeniable hit records or
is just so crazy that it's like yo this
[ __ ] King Lil G broke through
right right and he's selling out shows
all over the nation yeah he was on
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] was there no love
because he represented me and how I look
that's fair you understand what I'm
saying like the homie look at stole the
product that girl you know the product
she does shows everywhere does it she's
still not sure she just got nominated
for a Latin Grammy well thank God for
her God hey and snow is the you know
she's God level MC for sure okay so
that's what I'm saying like why why why
I don't know no the little girl Munch
just took off [ __ ] I don't know where
one Snow's never had one of those
records though what the [ __ ] and
everybody's flying around no I'm just
speaking facts you know I mean can Munch
this much that and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
like the track isn't that hard I mean
it's cool but you know it's a Tick-Tock
thing yeah but you guys know the product
slaughtering [ __ ] like I mean [ __ ] come
on bro like this snow is slaughtering
[ __ ] in her world in the same way that
like
think of tech Nine tech nine can wrap
his [ __ ] ass off I think she's more
dimensional than him oh of course
because she's she's I heard
um radio please that's not a direct like
correlation to their followings or their
music I see what you're saying you know
what I'm saying so I just think that
like yeah man I think I think that with
everything we've talked about what we
can both agree on is that it's all going
in a positive direction well yeah any
any any [ __ ] momentum is good I mean
look money sign swage it has a deal with
Atlantic Records oh yeah I mean cat G
was on Atlantic he's about to drop a
record with Jay Balvin you know you got
homies like me running around tearing
[ __ ] up man apparently 100 on their own
I'm doing features [ __ ] I
shouldn't be doing them yeah but I I
couldn't do them 15 years ago
[ __ ] just and you say you're
you got a project on the way with Benny
The Butcher yeah we gotta stop the
interview tell you about our partners at
Odd Socks well first of all let's check
out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by odd
Sox and we are proud to say so all right
let's get back to the interview yeah
well Benny's a friend of the family you
know so yeah I got some coming with the
boy in the future
um I just dropped my album Hunger Games
two I got prayers you got prayers on
their shots and prayers shots of prayers
prayers sold out wherever he goes into
Penny too yeah he's fine you know but he
don't rap but no he's fine either way
though he's doing it yeah he's still
married
he ain't letting her go yeah he ain't
letting that go hell no he got like the
the if it was a Selena Kat Von D's
probably next right I mean I would think
like the sweethearts of our community
you know yeah how like when you work
with someone like prayers who obviously
maybe uh sonically is a little bit but
he's a southsider like me right so we
Bond on that level that's what I'm
saying and
um and you know like there's something
to be said about our Brotherhood you
know what I'm saying like that South
Side Brotherhood is very um it's very um
how can you say it man like it's
automatic love bro you know yeah so we
gel We Vibe and it was It was a yeah it
was like a puzzle to put together you
know what I'm saying even the production
was was very hard to find but we did it
you know what I mean and I think it was
dope you know I'm saying like to bring
two worlds together that
that represent art you know what I'm
saying like we're not on some ignorant
just you know I mean making noise we
really try to make records you feel I'm
saying that's important yeah I think
that's important you gotta make records
man it's important so so yeah we just
did that um should we moving out here
you know I mean we we um as far as
myself personally I just concentrate on
on making timeless music dog like I'm
not here to follow Trends it's important
I'm not here to like um [ __ ] appease
anybody you know what I'm saying like
I'm just trying to follow my heart my
soul and and thus far [ __ ] just working
out it's led me to all the right look
I'm here with you yeah you know so I met
you we're backstage with Benny in them
yeah you were shroom the [ __ ] out always
you feel me look who's back there
Freeway Rick was back there the real
freeway rig who else is back to
Legendary people like Yeah The Crooked
Alchemist like think about these are all
people that I grew up like [ __ ] I met
Jay-Z I met Jay-Z where'd you meet Jay-Z
I mean Jay-Z you were there too food but
um I didn't say what's up to you where
at
um was this no I didn't because there's
so many people there first one is all
the show we went to the novel we were
all there
shout out to Jay-Z though I'm not saying
this too right you know but me and the
homie right we're in the hallway we're
the two only two essays in the hallway
in the green you know how the noble
setup yeah
so I'm a huge Jay-Z fan of course like
one of the only this will tell you one
of the only albums I had on the yard was
like Reasonable Doubt I had Reasonable
Doubt I had graduation and then I had um
mob deep
um Murder music you know fire classics
classics right
so those are the three albums that I'm
doing time with right so um [ __ ] like I
said okay so I'm I'm in I'm waiting for
Benny because I know how the shows end I
wanted to get to the back yeah you know
what it is yeah yeah before everybody's
all the rush comes in so I see um G pre
goes homeboy with him his older homie I
forgot his name but his OG homie I
recognize him first and then I that's
when Jake I had the dreads you know the
big thing so right away I was like oh
[ __ ] that's that's Jay-Z and the homie's
like no it's not like food trust me
that's whole food like you know so he
walks by and sure enough we see him but
I didn't want to you know hey what you
know what I'm saying like I don't know
I'd rather just admire a boy from the
distance you know and and enjoy the
moment
so he goes over there and then on the
way back Giga comes out by himself
literally you know and I'm tripping like
damn no security with a little boy like
what the [ __ ] and it's just me and the
homie stand in the corner and I'm
dressed almost like when I'm dressed
right now I got my gold on the homie got
way more [ __ ] than me but we're both
bald and we're chilling and Jay-Z walks
up to me right and he's like what's up
brother and I'm like what's up you know
I mean I didn't even know how to act to
be honest with you of course so I shake
his hand we exchange a few words polili
and then he leaves and then I pull out
my phone I take a picture from behind
around like oh no I would have got to
pick but I wanted to bro but I was
wondering
all my cool points can get thrown right
out the window like yo Jay look man yeah
I gotta get this so when he walks away
the I swear to y'all know why but the
first that comes to my mind I was like
damn I bet you I bet you Jay-Z thought
we were the plug
there's no way he thought I wrapped her
[ __ ] new rap you know what I'm saying
like I know for a fact this [ __ ]
thought we were we were the plug you
know what I'm saying but either way
though it was dope you feel the same but
um but yeah all that [ __ ] you know it's
all due to diligence and like hard work
and carrying yourself the right way you
know what I'm saying like I know a lot
of people highlight ignorance right now
but dog let me tell you like on the
Block what's gonna make you survive and
make you thrive is your intelligence you
know what I'm saying at the end of the
day like knowing how to move knowing
where to be at knowing how to conduct
yourself like all that loud mouth [ __ ]
is only good on the phone dog yeah when
it comes to real real business nobody
wants to sit
across the table from somebody that's a
that's a liability right you feel insane
and somebody that don't know about
investing somebody that doesn't
believe in the worth of where they're at
and what they're doing at the moment
like I know the word because Doug in the
blink of an eye could go back to the
cell I remember that [ __ ] vividly you
know what I'm saying right now what time
is it it's two o'clock right now I'd be
watching on the People's Court I'd be
watching The People's Court I'd be
getting ready to go out to yard right
two o'clock yard right man
the first unlock two o'clock we'd be
ready I'd have I'd be on the toilet no
lie three yards waiting for my door to
unlock while my celly is on the bunk
looking like a Raging Bull ready to come
out to the yard because we're that
excited to come out for a few [ __ ]
hours so crazy you know what I'm saying
I want to shout out to a couple of
artists we're talking about dope rappers
coyotes dope those those dudes are
incredible and a dough man from uh
Houston Houston yeah
yeah I had a little I had I had a
communication with the coyotes you know
when they um
well I'm sure they still signed a whack
but you know I just reached out to them
you know I'm saying and um
told them like man dog like there's
better ways to go about this [ __ ] I
would say that just because someone
signed to somebody doesn't necessarily
mean that they you know I feel you I say
that too but um
I mean to this point unfortunately their
Mexican artists signed a wax so yeah
exactly yeah yeah so you know but but
they're doing their thing [ __ ] you know
and you know it's all love you know what
I'm saying at the end of the day well
there it is man well look uh your album
is out hell yeah Hunger Games two the
price of integrity
bangers all the way through you a PC you
a [ __ ] don't listen to my [ __ ] you
ain't gonna like it though I guarantee
that night don't listen to my [ __ ] yeah
um you don't hustle you don't stand on
your word don't listen to my [ __ ] like
you ain't gonna like it you know there
it is facts appreciate you pulling up
and you picking this [ __ ] boom
appreciate it yes sir